cloud skills  are in high demand a massive 86 percent  of it leaders  say the skills shortage is slowing down  their cloud projects  there's now an easy way for you to hone  your cloud skills  fill this gap and demonstrate your cloud  competencies  introducing google cloud skill badges  you can earn badges for a range of  google cloud products and services  like bigquery kubernetes google  assistant  and more simply complete the interactive  labs  which cover the latest in-demand  real-world skills  you need today and take a final  assessment  pass that and the badge is yours  use your badges to gain recognition in  your current job  or to help land a new role in fact a  third of hr professionals  say that digital badges carry weight in  the hiring process  ready to go start earning google cloud  skill badges today